of course you would see a guy like Naz
rocking something from Dapper Dan
because dapper dan is his Virgil it's a
young person today who they love version
in love to Gerry Lorenz and they love
all those guys dapper dan was that guy
first
hey I'm Trinidad James I'm Spencer
Shapiro and today we're here to talk
about celebrities in the glasses Elton
John's really a pioneer in Iowa that guy
has so many different styles colors and
really he was one of the first to wear a
Cartier in 1983 they had a premiere
party at our collection and he was one
of the people to perform there he was
big on wearing the Cartier Moss it's
like a smaller frame so I noticed
Elton's been wearing a lot of frames
with red tense lately and personally I
love that red - the awesome color adds a
lot of pop to your wardrobe and I
incorporate that in a lot of my styles
I'm so used to seeing
Elden wear so many different colors I'm
not even I don't even pay attention to
color I'm more - the shape I mean I love
colors but when it comes to eyewear I'm
into the shapes of the hearts and the
squares and ovals and just finding new
shapes to fit your face to me is like
that everyday like challenge when
shopping for new shades and eyewear for
me is this finding a shape that works
with my face those look like
heart-shaped Gucci's that he has on like
heart shape like he's just always gonna
be influenced because he's not scared of
pushing the envelope you know he is he's
a alien and obviously that's someone who
does it all he's having fun with it
that's out and being out and doing this
thing really cool I like the turquoise
stones on the first pair what I probably
plastic this could be Gucci Gucci has
really been doing their thing lately
we're just you know really putting the
panel on the alessandro and everything
and doing over there Gucci they're just
going crazy
we're automatically putting the custom
to everything that they do so like how
these most mosquitoes I have here from
the 90s how they came with the stones
already on it from like 1990 wherever
Gucci's bringing it right back because
the 70s were just such an amazing era
when it came to fashion style
accessories you name it clothes like if
you look at the suit look at the lapels
on the jacket for Elle and you know it
makes sense for him to have those type
of glasses on like it's important to
have a great
you can never go wrong which is a great
plastic frame period I just got to say
that guy is a crazy style has stuff I've
never even seen before that bird and I
mean where do you start
I mean first of all is just excellence
walking excellence I'm from Harlem one
of the just most legendary designers
black designers period when you have the
type of talent that a man like that
possess you have to wear a certain type
of glasses like things are just not
regular the as you can see with the high
rating eyewear choices he's not a
regular guy and he's also doesn't have
the big his face but he still likes big
eyewear I wear an accessories they say a
lot they could tell it shows a lot about
your confidence you know it shows you
what type of person you are
like I said everybody can't pull these
off I'm not I would never tell them you
force anyone that you need to pull this
off but no just don't look at the table
like this and feel like oh no this is
all this is too much for me you don't
know that you got to find your way and I
love that for Dan for you know his work
with Gucci now the right way and I mean
just him being a pioneer just like a car
lock I look at him the same way you know
just tomorrow so you know it's really
awesome about the picture with the Gucci
glasses it says that for down beside is
really awesome because it reminds you it
kind of puts you in the mind of the
Casal coming up and well not coming up
in my name but in this day you know
those heyday like when the eighties were
just special and incredible when fashion
and and being a black designer was rare
it wasn't celebrated the way it needed
to be you've seen everybody from hip hop
artists of course like that for Dan
rocking the cool clear seat up gazelles
and him to take the Gucci glasses kind
of give you that feel again of the
Khazar but put his own dapper dan touch
on it with the svorski
I mean it's just pure confidence and
it's amazing seem to his thing you know
he's not a young man but he's rocking
things that young men don't even have
the capability and the idea yet of that
type of confidence of course you would
see a guy like nas rocking something
from Dapper Dan because dapper dan is
his Virgil it's a young person today who
day love version they love to cheer
Lorenz and they love all those guys
dapper dan was that guy
first all these guys a new and great and
amazing but you would see not rocking
down today rock the other branch too but
do you find this picture faster then
you'll find nas rocking these
millionaires or Deschanel Pharrell
simple as that
look for survive killin was such a big
influential person to fashion to models
to all these other young kids today who
want to understand whether this just
being a man you wanna know what is to be
the man the father look look at how
where he's winning then a legend
likewise love you know that oversized
eyewear but still is something there
about is like I got this big cage over
my face but I'm still letting you in you
can still see me and I just goes to show
you I want you to see me these guys want
you to see them but they're also hiding
their face is really interested Robert
Downey jr. he's just
that's all gee I love how he always has
different color tints different shades
it's not really a wild dresser but he
lets his eyewear talk for him those are
definitely a more modern a more modern
style not sure what the brand is it has
a custom yellow tint which is nice
because no still protects the eyes but
you can wear them indoors or outdoors
gives you a little bit of protection
against light but still see the eyes and
you can see that with all of his glasses
to me all those glasses you'll be able
to see his eyes but they do have a tin
on them that plays to his coolness you
know it's almost like having transition
lenses you walk out saying the Sun dark
boom cover your eyes you come inside you
when people see what we're gonna feel
your president he's not scared to look
you in the face
none of them are dark to dark you can't
see his eyes and there's also if you're
paying attention to it he keeps her
square like he finally he found a shape
any like Springs eyes it's a science to
this it's not just picking up glass and
putting the ball after wild you bought
10 20 30 40 50 100 pairs of glasses it
becomes a science the blue lens would a
guy like Robert or I like to call some
stock with Tony Stark
that's a Tony Stark pair glasses he
could wait everyday but I just feel like
a person has so many different pairs of
sunglasses that's just a good one you
know he's the guy who's about his teens
he probably gets custom tends to
Northtown he finds those frames are
really like you ain't
his eyes that really bring with they're
actually giving a whole new lens put in
it's custom cut and dyed they basically
remove it from the frame they trace it
in the Machine and then they're gonna
custom mix the dye to the color of your
choice cotton candy three colors even
this like I made 3d glasses so you know
one side red one side blue and you can
actually look at a 3d image and see it
popping out when you're wearing these
next we got Spike Lee I mean the og a
person who is definitely about their
look as you can see he has found his
shape usually I see him wearing more of
a Wayfarer style wears a lot of brown
frames too with the thick rim around the
Spike Lee has been around for every time
regular movies doing commercials with
Michael Jackson Michael Jordan you know
just being on the scene and picking up
different styles from all over the world
but as you can see he still allows you
to see his face and it kind of just
shows you I would assume that spike is a
serious guy
and I feel that when he puts on eyewear
and it's accessories it means business
but there's no fun he's a fun guy you
love sneakers and you could see the
colorways and the things that he loves
about Jordans and Nikes come out in his
ivory especially goes to the game you
pop out the orange frame probably has an
orange a blue shoe or I would imagine
you know match it up even the purple
outfit I think that was the Oscars when
he won his first Oscar you know he had
gold Jordans on I was purple suit purple
friend department hat with the glasses
and accessories is really a madness to
it in that double frame it's something
I've never seen before but I really like
it a lot he likes the color of the frame
itself pop and he keeps the tint simple
so you know usually keeps his regular
prescription lenses in their order just
you know a light gray or black tint so
that's something that's really unique
Samuel Jackson the legend the man
himself style untouched our man who
knows what he wants we'll do it a shade
will do you can see my eyes you never
know your kind of differ a little bit
different and slightly kinda similar and
then another style but you're switching
up we give you a dark kid give you a
see-through also that grape tangle that
thing is amazing
so what he's wearing right now is what
they call a semi rimless like a half
frame frame so top edge is kind of
floating and then it's supported by a
rim underneath Samuel Jackson's not the
young man is really amazing to see their
eyewear transcend going into 20/20 like
they're not when male street plastics
like they're wearing new frames and new
styles and new tints and you know
putting together outfits with these
glasses this beautiful thing they don't
even think about names you don't know
how they are when you're in their
presence and you look at their eyewear
their accessories their outfits it's
right on time so growing up I've always
been a collector of all sorts of things
I started on you know in sneakers bait
all types of luxury goods you know as a
teenager I started off working at local
boutique called the vibe back in Detroit
that really got me into the scene so
from there I'd see all types of people
coming in wearing rare Cartier's very
Prasad she Alpena all types of these
brands you know especially Cartier
considering that being a huge fashion
staple in Detroit so from there you know
I really just saved up some money got my
first pair of frames and ended up
turning into a business
I'm very similar to Spenser like myself
him growing up in Detroit it kind of
very it reflects to our collection if
you cease heavy cartier grow up in
Detroit I grew up in Atlanta and a few
other places where you know I only have
one pair of card ears per se on my table
but just different styles like I've seen
150,000 the things that he used to wear
back in the day and like characters like
Little John the young bloods and so many
different artists that I grew up paying
attention to these are areas you
recognize these remind you of Kurt
Cobain
some eyewear for a lot of celebrities
they have a staple piece
like that's their thing and there's
nothing wrong with that like for me all
these are my things
but for cargo but this is this thing
Kristen raw from 92 they discontinued
these this particular pair of shades
also owned Spencer has the huge massage
massage is a biggie smalls
you know these were classic for him
ulcers not to say he didn't wear other
glasses but when you think biggie
you just so known for these yeah
[Music]